[Music]
yo what's up tron identity what a way to
start the show welcome to the first ever
disney and marvel games showcase i'm
your host blessing adeyoye jr and today
i'll be your npc guide as you quest
through game announcements from disney
pixar marvel lucasfilm in 20th century
now if you want to keep up to date with
biffle games first adventure in the
expanded tron universe and their
upcoming collaborations with disney
games be sure to follow their socials in
fact you should probably drop a follow
on all the disney game socials for more
info on today's world premieres like
this one right here
[Music]
mickey minnie
donald goofy we bid
[Music]
tell us what you need toku our entire
world is in danger
you must travel to the three biomes of
monarch and retrieve the books of
knowledge
[Music]
if others are in need we should help
them
[Music]
don't you worry taco we'll do it hang on
the books are gone
[Music]
it's okay we'll explain
[Music]
tbd dvd tbd
wait are those placeholder words or the
actual words
yes
that was awesome i got dibs on goofy
y'all disney illusion island debuts
exclusively on the nintendo switch
system and whether you're looking to run
solo or couch co-op with up to three
friends as the fab four you can put it
on your wish list today
now if you've been wishing for more info
on marvel's midnight suns i've got you
in this rpg from the tactical geniuses
at firaxis games you play as the hunter
the first customizable original hero in
a marvel game lead blade magic ghost
rider nico minoru and more in a fight
against lilith mother of demons plus the
elder god c'thon with revolutionary card
based tactics featured in this all-new
gameplay trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you heard what the trailer said marvel's
midnight sons is coming out this year on
december 2nd for windows pc playstation
5 and xbox series x and s and it's
available to pre-order today but that's
not all right now we have a sneak peek
of the intro for the set of new prequel
shorts that gives a never-before-seen
preview of the heroes that you'll be
playing as
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that looks like it's gonna be dope
be sure to follow at marvel games and
the midnight sun social channels for
more information
and now here's some exciting news about
a marvel game you can play today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
now listen i know you came here for the
trailers and dlc announcements and big
reveals and not me but i'm cool with
that because i want to see what's next
too so let's get to it
oh hi there you look like someone who's
ready to join me on a wild ride to the
multiverse what's that you have plans
right now we'll cancel them
welcome to marvel snap
you can access it from anywhere your
house your workplace bathroom at your
workplace
let's be honest most likely in the
bathroom am i right it's clobbering time
and it's as easy to play as solitaire
actually easier i don't think i've ever
won a game of solitaire
but here's the twist these cards are
super powered like the entire canon of
marvel characters kind of superpower
maybe you like me would love to see
kick thanos evil purple butt
or you've always wondered what the
guardians of the galaxy would look like
an 8-bit mode well
wonder no more
it's easy to pick up and so much fun to
master
in other words less time than a bagel
takes to toast who doesn't have a
bagel's worth of time
so don't wait to explore a multiverse of
possibilities
marvel snap it's time to make your move
the game launches on october 18th
pre-register now at marvelsnap.com
yeah i can get with that don't forget to
set a reminder to download marvel snap
on your android and ios devices on
october 18th and be sure to stick around
here for more marvel reveals later in
the showcase but first next year gamers
are getting dropped into the middle of a
xenomorph outbreak in the tactical squad
based action of aliens dark descent
in this look at gameplay take your squad
of marines on missions as you infiltrate
and investigate the xenomorph outbreak
develop your tactics assemble your
colonial marines and take on the
xenomorph hordes in aliens dark descent
next year on consoles and pc
but first let's talk about avatar and
revisit pandora in avatar frontiers of
pandora you'll be immersed in the beauty
and danger of the alien moon and
experience a living and reactive world
firsthand as a na'vi you'll explore new
environments and interact with all new
creatures plants and characters in the
never before seen western frontier
fighting against the rda in a brand new
standalone story for pc and next-gen
consoles
now from pandora to a galaxy far far
away lego star wars the skywalker saga
destroyed sales records like rebels
taking out death stars if you haven't
picked it up yet or you've already blown
up all the death stars too here's
another reason to jump into the
skywalker saga new characters including
cassie and andor
riva
captain rex and more are coming to lego
star wars the skywalker saga soon take
on even more stormtroopers lead a
lightsaber or the force
part of your way through the galaxy and
get ready to expand your character
collection
[Music]
the galactic edition comes out this
holiday season with 13 character packs
including 6 all new ones adding some of
your favorite characters
now for those who don't know lucasfilm
games is known for more than just star
wars titles today the voice of guybrush
threepwood dominic armado is here to
share a look at the upcoming return to
monkey island
hello fellow pirates my name is dominic
armado the voice of guy brush 3 foot
don't be fooled by the name the monkey
island adventure series is about pirates
not monkeys it's been a part of the
lucasfilm family of games for more than
30 years beginning in 1990 with the
secret of monkey island i want to be a
pirate
through the years each game has been
carefully crafted to feature the humor
clever puzzles and sense of adventure
that made monkey island such an iconic
video game series plus we've got some
outstanding voice acting a wonderful new
musical score and a gorgeous illustrated
art style
we've also put together an in-game
scrapbook in which gaibar streetwood
details his adventures and important
moments from previous games it's a great
way to get caught up on what's happened
so far or a fun refresher if you already
know the whole story
we can't wait for you to discover the
secrets hidden in return to monkey
island play it on nintendo switch or pc
on september 19th
you can strap on an eye patch and
celebrate talk like a pirate day on
september 19th by picking up returned
monkey islands
lucasfilm games isn't the only team
bringing the nostalgia vibes today
over the last few years disney games has
revived classics like aladdin the jungle
book and the lion king and now they're
teaming up with empty clip to bring back
another classic gargoyles remastered
a fan favorite that's sure to have you
screaming like a viking heated by
goliath
yep that's the scream
and while you'll have to wait to climb
back into the world of gargoyles
remastered you can grab your phone and
start unlocking heroes in this disney
and pixar action rpg right now
[Music]
when the call goes out for heroes
you never know who will answer
sometimes the best hero
is a villain
someone little sinister
who will get the job done
and doesn't care who they have to push
aside
[Music]
even if it means forging devious
alliances to fulfill their schemes
[Music]
after all there is strength in numbers
especially when that number is
number one
[Music]
i'd suggest downloading disney mirror
verse and leveling up your teams like
now if you're hoping to take on hades
and the other villains dropping this
october alright let's get into our next
review
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
i wonder how many miles per screen mike
wazowski's pulling i guess we'll all
find out together when disney's speed
storm drops on pc and console
and now let's take a stroll through an
idyllic disney neighborhood
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hey there
[Music]
oh you are
[Music]
thanks
roger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you want to help out some of your
favorite disney and pixar friends in
disney dreamlight valley right now good
news you can with xbox game pass or by
grabbing the founders pack on your pc or
just about every console you own
now for those who are looking for an
action-packed mmorpg shooter that you
can play in the palm of your hand look
no further than avatar reckoning
soon you'll be able to battle for the
future of pandora on your phone but for
now we've got jared yeager an executive
producer at walt disney games here to
tell you more
hey everyone i'm excited to give you a
sneak peek at the upcoming avatar
reckoning in this mmorpg shooter you'll
return to the moon of pandora to find
your own way in the aftermath of the
battle of the hallelujah mountains
as you begin your adventure you'll
customize your own avatar warrior you'll
also be able to collect and customize a
range of weapons to prepare you for your
journey
as you set out across single-player
missions you'll discover new regents as
you unravel a mysterious story
encountering new clans and defending
yourself from the perils of pandora from
creatures to the rda forces you'll also
be able to play both with and against
others in online multiplayer team up in
instances to battle with other players
trying to survive against powerful
enemies or battle in player versus
player mode where you'll team up against
other players across a variety of maps
you'll be able to experience all of this
and more when avatar reckoning hits your
mobile device soon
and now another world premiere
[Music]
hey
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
oh let's freaking go i know you're
probably hopping onto reddit to break
down all those easter eggs but i
recommend you don't tab away just yet
because there's another world premiere
from marvel games coming your way right
now
[Music]
[Music]
and there it is the first ever disney
and marvel games showcase i hope you had
as much fun as i did i'm blessing ida jr
thanks for joining us it's been our
pleasure to serve you